and no surprises there she's been
sticking to the lines we've heard before
and a narrow legal definition of
genocide yes I think you're exactly
right no surprises in what we just heard
in that long opening statement from
Myanmar state councilor on Sun Tzu Chi
it started out very much as expected
with a history lesson of the complex
background to the situation that we see
unfolding over the past few years and
continuing to unfold in Rakhine State
the tensions over the decades between
the Buddhist and Muslim communities in
that state but what she didn't do really
is address the issues the discrimination
that is faced by the Rohingya
communities and has been faced by them
for a very long time she again in the
past has refused to even use the word
Ranga when describing this ethnic group
which as we know is not regarded as an
official ethnic group in Myanmar they
are regarded as illegal immigrants she
only in this speech that we just heard
used that word Ranga when referring to
the militant group the Rohingya militant
group that attacked the security forces
in 2016 and 2017 the overriding theme of
this speech I think was that this court
the International Court of Justice is
not where these allegations of crimes
committed by the Myanmar security forces
should be decided basically she was
saying that this is an internal
situation they have the justice system
both within the military in terms of a
court martial system and the criminal
justice system to handle this and any
crimes against humanity that have been
committed by security forces or indeed
by civilians in Rakhine State can be and
will be handled handled domestically and
that certainly as she pointed out on
several occasions in that speech is not
a case of genocide when we've seen
demonstrators both in in Myanmar and
outside the court where you're standing
in support of her so clearly all of this
really resonates with many of the people
from Myanmar and has for many years
yes it has and you know one of the
things that she pointed out in this
speech and has pointed out many times
before and in fact it was one of the
first things she mentioned in the speech
is that this is a very complex situation
in Rakhine State and yes there is a very
strong nationalist Buddhist movement
within me and ma that still exists today
so to some extent she may well be
playing to that audience to that base in
the lead-up to an election next year in
which of course she's hoping to be
reelected we saw large gatherings in
Myanmar as she was departing for the
Netherlands to appear at the
International Court of Justice some
people have travelled with her to
support it we've seen a few hundred
people gathered here outside the court
in the past few hours supporting her as
she arrived on Tuesday when the Gambians
opened their case opened this genocide
case we saw opponents of Aung San su Chi
supporters of the Ranga cause are coming
here as well to voice their support of
the Ranger case to voice their criticism
of Aung San su Chi and her government so
yes that support and the protesters
still here and we expect they will be
here for the closing of this this case
on for the moment anyway on Thursday
when hey there live for us in the hey
he's been following those hearings and
will continue to do so Thank You Wayne
well let's go live now to Stephanie
Decker fees and Cox's Bazaar in
Bangladesh with more than 700 thousand
reinga refugees staff I imagine the
people that are trying to follow us very
closely and Aung San su Chi has now
admitted the use of disproportionate
force says there were civilian
casualties but says there wasn't
genocidal intent how does that square
with the stories that you've been
hearing from refugees
well you only have to look at the
various camp here that stretch all the
way to the Myanmar border which were the
mountains and the distance it's quite a
hazy day it's the biggest refugee camp
in the world now and this is a
consequence of whatever it is happened
in all this of 2017 if you decide to
believe on some suci saying yes
disproportionate force what is that
classify as well we've been covering
this story myself and colleague our
colleagues since day one
what chains of thousands of people flee
within the space of two weeks carrying
nothing barefoot
just their babies whatever belongings
they could telling stories of macerate
people being chopped into pieces being
people being burnt inside homes so this
is a story of every single country has a
similar story a similar tragedy it's
been very difficult listening to these
stories over the years some of them are
so terrible that you think they're
unbelievable but when you have such a
mass of people giving a very similar
account of what happened
you must question what kind of
atrocities were committed by the Myanmar
military so yes people here at
protecting on a point that Wayne
mentioned we spoke to a community leader
just earlier he said this is not about
her defending any genocide yes or no
this is about reelection this is about
domestic politics this is why she has
taken the forefront of something that
she has tried to remain quite quiet
about so we're gonna have to wait and
see what the court rules but certainly I
think it's going to be very difficult to
see whatever that ruling is in the hate
to have an impact on the future of these
people here well Stefan sans duty also
has been promising domestic
accountability and one of the things she
said was that human rights violations
and Rakhine State won't be tolerated I
mean that's quite a big statement given
the number of people around you who've
run away from these atrocities how is
that likely to be perceived by the
refugees there
yes and also the fact that to continuing
documentation reports out of the ranga
that still reside in Rakhine State give
a picture because it's very difficult to
access as a journalist as a foreign
journalist even the United Nations no
one can access that area that
discrimination continues they're
confined to camp they're not allowed to
have access to education certainly the
repatriation program that was in place
here to try and get some of these people
to start going home because of course
they do want to go home they don't want
to live in these kinds of conditions but
they don't trust the situation they
don't believe that they're going to be
safe they don't believe that what has
happened before who can't happen again
so these are the big question marks
about the future of these people human
rights violations while it's a broad
term genocide will intent has to do with
targeting a group because of their
ethnicity because of their makeup and
that is what people here will tell you
and as you heard from Wei Wayne as well
over the decades that has been a case
that the rahaga say has been their
situation they're not even seen as you
know as residents of bian mar so I think
it's a very complicated situation going
forward particularly when it comes to
resolving this because Bangladesh is
frustrated they don't want them here
anymore I can tell you we've been
harassed throughout the day by security
forces here trying to stop us from doing
our work even though we have permissions
it's very sensitive
these are tense times they've cut the
internet they're trying to fence the
camps we don't know where this is going
to go and this concern also about a
potential insurgency coming out of this
in the future if people are not given
opportunity and being able to go home so
I think very difficult times ahead
and yes this case is significant isn't
going to resolve anything it's going to
be difficult Stephanie Decker they're
bringing us the view from Cox's Bazar
Thank You Stephanie